it's a big day for Iraq's Kurds
long lines formed early in front of
polling stations in the Kurdish
autonomous region the Kurdish city of
halabja the site of a poison gas attack
by Saturday signs forces that killed
thousands almost 30 years ago a symbol
of why many here want independence we
support the referendum if it's in the
interest of the people people will not
support it though if it will cause more
Wars or cause people to flee their homes
we have had enough of Wars and
deportation we do not want more Wars and
destruction of our homes before the vote
Kurdish regional government president
Masoud Barzani explained why he was
pressing ahead unfortunately the state
that we have right now in Iraq it is a
theocratic sectarian state neck double
attack you must have be okay I would
like to underline that we are never ever
going back to Baghdad to renegotiate in
Baghdad iraqi prime minister haider
al-abadi condemned the referendum what
the map of Iraq is endangered by a
tensed division and tearing us apart
discrimination between Iraqi citizens on
a nationalistic or ethnic basis exposes
Iraq to dangers known only to God
Turkey's Deputy Prime Minister Bakir Baz
dag said Kurdish leaders were playing
with fire and would be the first to be
burned the UN the United States and
other Western countries had urged
Kurdish leaders to postpone the
referendum but they refused to back down
many Kurds are expected to vote in favor
of a break off but the non-binding vote
is unlikely to trigger an immediate
formal declaration of independence